[Musica]
all
siamo nel 1994 alla radio sono il
nuovissimo city hit mania dance a 94 che
non so quanti di voi se lo ricordano ma
qualcuno ha già ammesso di aver giocato
a pongo quindi sicuramente qualcuno se
lo ricorda bene quell'anno 1994
mio padre se ne tornò a casa con un
enciclopedia se ne ha fatto intortare da
un venditore che gli aveva venduto
pensate l'enciclopedia più piccola del
mondo
l'enciclopedia di per sé occupava poco
più spazio di una scatola di scarpe ma
semplicemente perché la contenuta in 96
floppy disk floppy disk pensate
all'epoca pensate che erano talmente
avanti negli anni 90 che assieme
all'enciclopedia si regalavano anche un
computer per leggerla pensate che anni
meravigliosi che erano quelle dunque a
mio padre per una casa con un
enciclopedia un computer che occupava
più spazio dell'enciclopedia di carta ed
un tecnico per installarla
io rimasi subito affascinata dalla cosa
e ricordo che rimasi incantato a
guardare quel tecnico che collegava
quelle che all'epoca parevano decine e
decine di cavi
alla fine il tecnico acceso il computer
e mi fece vedere le insicuro pedina di
per sé erano solo dei minuscoli
trafiletti di testo ed alcune immagini a
256 colori a malapena si distingueva
l'immagine della sfinge da quella di un
gatto pensata l'utilità era fine il
tecnico come disse una frase che tutto
il ricordo perfettamente mi disse per
uscire dal programma dell'enciclopedia
deve cliccare sul tasto qui mi fa è come
il vice del topo scritto qui liquidas
quiete ricordi il dopo l'uscita
è una storia
bene dopo avervi fornito questo unica ed
impagabile informazione il tecnico se ne
andò e mi lascia da solo davanti al mio
computer alle scope diana cominciai
subito ad esplorare questo nuovissimo
strumento di per sé l'enciclopedia era a
dir poco mortalmente scomoda dove i
cambiare i floppy ogni pochi minuti
perché a volte anche una singola voce è
la divisa su più dischi è l'unica cosa
che mi è rimasta impressa di quale il
ciclope di a è il costante l'umore di
lettura dei floppy che simile un grande
margine perché fa un piacevole al che
appunto ha stressato dalla cosa mi
ricordai il famoso verso del topo
scritta ed uscì dal programma
dell'enciclopedia finalmente e mi trovai
di fronte ad uno schermo completamente
nero con solo un piccolo rettangolino
lampeggiante in basso e capi che poteva
usare la tastiera per scrivere delle
cose
c'era chi ha poca o scrisse command not
found mi rispose come va chiesi
nuovamente common not found passi avanti
io all'epoca non conoscevo l'inglese e
non avevo assolutamente idea di cosa
volesse dire quel kong non fa però
pensare di chiedere al mio nuovo
computer
cosa vuol dire command not found com of
town mi rispose subito anche pensare beh
sarcastico ma un po di logica ce l'ha mi
piace
e fu così che nacque il mio rapporto con
l'informatica ed è così che molto spesso
nasce un hacker ma che cos'è un hacker
beh innanzitutto un hacker non è
assolutamente il cybercriminale che viva
rubare i dati della carta di credito
lacker a me piace definirlo come un
bambino curioso che ha trovato il suo
parco giochi
complicatissimo universo
dell'informatica che è un universo
veramente complesso è formato di
migliaia d'identità migliaia di
programmi e sottoprogrammi interconnessi
tra loro e che lavorano in simbiosi fate
30 ad esempio il vostro telefono quando
dovete inviare un sms con la fate lo
prende dalla tasca lo sbloccate scrivete
il messaggio e lo inviate in questa
semplicissima operazione avete coinvolto
facevo contarle tira fuori il telefono
si accende il display un programma che
accende il display un programma che
legge di impronta digitale e sblocca il
telefono un programma che ha per la
tastiera pop up mi permette digitale
un programma che mi fa scrivere il
messaggio siamo arrivati a 4
e ancora dobbiamo inviare il nostro sms
se poi pensate che ognuno di questi
programmi ha sotto di sé per funzionare
altre decine di sottoprogrammi vi
rendete conto quanta complicata il mondo
dell'informatica e 40 complicata anche
una singola operazione
bene questo bambino che è cresciuto
all'interno di questo complicatissimo
mondo ora acquisita una tale confidenza
con questo universo che adesso riesce a
vedere degli schemi delle
interconnessioni tra queste entità che
gli altri non riescono a vedere è una
volta che si ha la capacità di vedere
schemi che altri non vedono è anche
facile vedere gli errori gli errori
delle sviste che hanno commesso i
programmatori che hanno costruito
quell'universo è la chiave è proprio
questa gli errori errori informati si
errori che voi conoscerete come i bug
quelli che gli fanno che lasciare il
computer quelli che gli fanno perdere le
foto delle vostre vacanze che voi avete
salvato benissimo
esattamente quegli errori la sono gli
strumenti degli hacker gli hacker quindi
con la fanno cercano o a volte
semplicemente trovano gli errori nei
software ma ripeto non per creare danni
commettere crimini o qualunque cosa è
lesta ma semplicemente perché quello è
il loro gioco
beh ora la domanda
vien da sé ma com'è che si sfruttano
questi bug cosa vuol dire sfruttare i
banner
facciamo un esempio della casa avete
appena costruito la vostra nuova casa è
bella accogliente grande e spaziosa ci
andate ad abitare la mette arredata con
tutto quello di cui avete bisogno la
televisione gigantesca e il frigo che fa
il ghiaccio all'android design il letto
king size avete tutto quello che
desiderate adorate la vostra nuova casa
alla sera
andate a dormire e la mattina dopo mi
risvegliate sul pavimento
perché qualcuno aveva svaligiato la casa
me lo porto via tutto anche il letto
tutto tutto vi guardate in giro cercato
di capire un po cosa sia mai successo e
vi accorgete che la porta sul retro
era una porta di cartone si una porta di
cartone qualcuno vi aveva montato verrà
installato in casa una porta di cartone
un errore dozzinale un errore da
principianti ma diciamo che va bene così
basse dove di sistemarla mettete mano al
portafoglio l'ha sostituita con una
porta nuova più resistente di legno
massiccio con l'anima in titanio 4
serratura vi dimettete al sicuro ma a
questo punto visto che avete ormai messo
mano al vostro portafoglio perché non
aggiungere alla vostra casa anche un bel
cammino nuovo
tornate a casa la riarredate ovviamente
alla sera belli soddisfatti andata a
dormire sul nostro nuovissimo letto king
size il secondo è la mattina dopo
indovinate un po dove vi svegliate sul
pavimento
perché qualcuno di nuovo viene da
svaligiato la casa durante la notte due
volte come me hanno fatto questa volta
primo pensiero controllo la porta sul
retro la porta sul retro è intatta
e guardate in giro tutto a posto finché
vi viene il dubbio che siano forse
entrate dal camino prendete il vostro
fidato m che per fortuna non vi hanno
rubato misurate il diametro del camino
né vi accorgete che effettivamente la
una persona ci passa bene quindi li
mettete mano al portafoglio chiamate la
ditta fate stringere il diametro del
camino e mi mettete in sicurezza
benissimo
secondo voi perché è successo tutto
questo perché quel cammino è la troppo
largo
perché chi si occupa di porte chi si
occupa di camini non si occupa di porta
non riesce a vedere il camino come un
entrata come un buco d'ingresso non
riesce a vedere che c'è
un'interconnessione tra un camino ed una
porta
morale della favola sarebbe stato
veramente bellissimo
aveva avuto a disposizione un architetto
con una visione d'insieme della vostra
casa e che vedesse le varie possibili
interconnessioni tra tutte le sue
componenti restelli tutt e due furti in
casa deve allora tutto questo significa
saper sfruttare i bug i nostri laden e
l'ho sfruttato i bug da uno
semplicissimo come una porta di cartone
che puramente reso con un calcio a
quello più complicato come
l'interconnessione che c'è tra un camino
ed una porta ma cosa ne fanno gli hacker
di questi bug cosa ne fanno di queste
informazioni che che trovano equa che il
mondo degli hacker si divida il web da
un lato ci sono gli hacker con un'etica
e cosa fanno
regalano al mondo le loro scoperte per
evitare che qualcuno possa usarle per
fini malevoli per fini criminosi
è come se un architetto esperto
passeggiasse davanti alla nostra casa
notasse il cammino troppo largo
decidessi di contattarci per avvisarci
ci guadagnerebbe un semplice grazie ma
sicuramente sarebbe bello soddisfatto di
aver resa più sicura un'abitazione
dall'altro lato abbiamo gli hacker senza
un'etica che sfruttano a proprio
vantaggio nello scoperte per commettere
crimini per violare i sistemi oppure con
la fanno e rivendono le loro scoperte a
qualcuno che abbia diciamo la necessità
di violare un sistema comunque
assolutamente niente di buono
immaginate l'architetto di prima che si
traveste da spazzacamino e va a
svaligiare la casa sarebbe più o meno
così oppure peggio che li vendesse
l'indirizzo della sventurata maggiore
alla malavita organizzata
il risultato non si guadagneranno un
semplice grazie ma probabilmente si
ritroverebbe ben più ricco della media
dei suoi colleghi architetti un hacker
dunque ad un certo punto della propria
vita si trova di fronte ad un bivio
morale
deve decidere se svaligiare case o
aiutare a renderle più sicure se
preferisce l'etica al profitto ebbene è
proprio l'etica che divida in due il
mondo degli hacker è chiaramente non
solo quello
un anno fa circa mi sono trovato di
fronte a quella che amo definire una
situazione eticamente significativa
quando ho trovato un grosso bug su una
componente del sistema thor
per chi non lo sa toro è un sistema che
permette di navigare in internet
restando anonimi nel bene e nel male e
bene la mia scoperta permetteva proprio
questo cioè di andare a te anonimizzare
ovvero rivelare la vera identità degli
utenti di thor e non vi nascondo che
appena scoperta questa cosa quasi per
caso ho voluto prima sensazione paura
folle perché ritrovi in mano un'arma
pericolosa
capisci che da un lato può fare gol a
molte persone e dall'altro può costare
la vita a qualcuno non penso di
esagerare definirla un arm
immaginate ad esempio un giornalista che
vive e lavora in uno di quei paesi dove
la libertà di parola non è esattamente
garantita per una di queste persone
l'anonimato è una questione di
sopravvivenza quindi un esagerato
definirlo marmo ebbene la scelta etica è
stata esattamente questa contattare gli
architetti di thor ed avvisarli che
nella loro nel loro sistema c'è un
cammino troppo largo il risultato è
stato che pochi giorni dopo thor era
nuovamente al sicuro e vi dico che è
stata una scelta estremamente semplice
semplicissimo
mi sono ricordato di quel bambino che
giocava con il computer
quel computer che all'inizio gli
rispondeva sempre solo command not found
com not found ma che non l'ha fatto
desistere dal continuare a provare e
riprovare con la sua tastiera provare a
parlare con questa macchina
finché questa macchina non ha cominciato
a darmi delle risposte sempre più
sensate e sempre meno sarcastiche e bene
la mia scoperta e anche di quel bambino
è sicuramente quel bambino non avrebbe
mai voluto vedere trasformato il suo
gioco
il suo amico di latta in un'arma grazie
[Applauso]
grazie